total tax paid for Securus Dharma for
the tax period
2021-22 was just over 67
000 pounds it shows that he made a
capital gains contribution of 85
466 pounds in that Financial year on
which he paid 2 23 930 in capital gains
tax uh it said that the sum reflected
his share of the capital gains when his
sister decided to sell a house that he
had helped her buy this was on top of
his
154 pounds a year income for being an MP
and leader of the opposition so in the
period
2021-22 that tax year
um income tax
just over 43 000 pounds he paid just
over 23 000 pounds in capital gains and
that brings a total of tax paid of just
over 67
000 pounds that's in comparison to the
Prime Minister who paid a total tax last
year of 432
000 pounds in that same period let's
bring in our correspondent Amanda acas
I'll be the sigh of relief not great on
tax and figures but Amanda's been taking
a look through
um so that total tax paid in that year
just over 67 000 pounds and which may or
may not have been expected but what's
the reason for secure releasing this
remind us
yes so Sakia promised in January that he
would release his tax returns along with
the deputy uh labor leader and uh the uh
labor Chancellor if they win the next uh
general election but now Rishi sunak has
released his tax returns while a summary
of them
um sakistan has obviously decided that
in the interest of transparency he needs
to release his equivalent information
now it's not actually as we saw with the
Prime Minister it's not actually a
formal tax return rather it's a kind of
summary of the income and tax paid
altogether
um and I think it is really quite
striking the comparison with the kind of
amounts that we saw from the Prime
Minister who clearly is a very
independently wealthy man so as you say
there Sakia stammer paid 67
000 pounds in tax his total income
um was uh in terms of his savings and
the income he made from his salary as an
MP and leader of the opposite position
was a total of 126
621 pounds now in terms of
um that comparison with the Prime
Minister well his income from earnings
and savings came in at um just under
double that so 329 000 pounds but the
real difference is about the
differentiation in the amount of capital
gains made by the prime minister so last
year and that was a figure of 1.6
million that he made in capital gains
whereas a secure stamas
um equivalent figure was 85 000 which we
do have an explanation on this from his
accountant saying that this is because
he'd bought a house with his sister for
her and her children to live in
um so this reflects the share of the
capital gains made when his sister
decided to sell that property so um
clearly
um it's it's still a lot of money but in
comparison with the total figure for the
Prime Minister it's over obviously very
different so just to summarize again the
total tax paid by secure stamina last
year 67 000 pounds in comparison with
more than 400 000 pounds for the same
period uh paid by uh Rishi sunak uh
reflecting the very different amounts of
capital gains made by the Prime Minister
and other prime minister's um
Investments were largely tied up in a
trust which is set up in America because
of course that's where much of his
financial career was based before he
went into politics it's held in a blind
trust which is something that
politicians tend to set up when they
take office which means that they don't
actually control where those Investments
are made the idea is to avoid a conflict
of interest but critics also argue that
it's not good for transparency because
also it means that they don't have an
obligation to disclose where those
Investments are made and they do know
what they are when they first initially
made although they don't have control
over subsequent decisions so there are
always questions asked about those
although no suggestions that anything
improper has been done but I think it's
interesting that we're seeing these
returns being being released I mean in
America there is an expectation and that
political leaders the president's not
Donald Trump of course but previous
presidents have released their uh tax
returns it's not something the British
prime ministers
um or political leaders have typically
done the last prime minister to do it
was David Cameron Boris Johnson and Liz
trust didn't do so Jeremy corbyn and
John McDonnell did though so for labor
perhaps there is more of a a more recent
track record but obviously the question
of senior political leaders finances
have really come into scrutiny over the
past year we had the Scandal over the
penalty paid by Nadine zahawi when he
was Chancellor and then we also had the
questions raised over the non-dom status
um of Rishi sunak's wife who of course
is a very wealthy woman she's the
daughter of an Indian billionaire she
was born in India so that's why she had
that non-dom status on her worldwide
income but obviously questions were
asked there was an uproar because she
was the wife of the chancellor of the
exchequer obviously in charge of the UK
tax system at the time so in response to
that she said she would voluntarily
start paying tax on her worldwide income
um clearly um Mr sunax tax return which
was released yesterday didn't include
his wife's taxable income but obviously
that's why there's such a scrutiny uh
because the the that the soon acts are
believed to be the most wealthy couple
ever to have inhabited uh Downing
streets so cleanly now Mr sunac says
he's he's done this in the interest of
transparency so kirstama wants to follow
since but I think the key issue that
many Saw with the Mr sunax Tax Returns
was really this huge amount of capital
gains that he had made and the fact that
the the tax rate for capital gains is is
so much lower than the tax tax rate for
income so he paid the tax rate around 20
percent on that indeed that's what
secure stamma would have paid on his
capital gains as well
um but many really Quest why in in a
time when there's such a cost of living
crisis it is that the wealthy who tend
to be the ones who make more of their
income from Investments and capitals
gains can benefit from that lower tax
rate compared to the tax on incomes
which more people rely on of course